la violence se déplace très rapidement
dans les rues adjacentes et près de la
mairie du 18e les forces de l'ordre
harcelées riposte les arrestations se
multiplient
[Musique]
drame cet après-midi dans un
commissariat du 18e arrondissement de
Paris un adolescent était mortellement
blessé par l'arme de service d'un
policier qui l'interrogeait sur place
Christophe Tortora il est impossible de
s'approcher du commissariat des grandes
carrières dans le 18e arrondissement de
Paris la rue a été totalement bloquée
par un important dispositif policier
dans ce commissariat cet après-midi un
mineur a été tué par l'arme de
l'inspecteur qui l'interrogeait pour
l'instant on ignore tous les
circonstances exactes du drame seul
certitude le jeune homme avait été placé
cette nuit en garde à vue on ne connaît
pas encore les motifs de son
interpellation le substitut lui
procureur de la République s'est
immédiatement rendu sur place ainsi que
le patron de la police judiciaire
parisienne ni l'un ni l'autre où on fait
une déclaration l'IGS l'inspection
générale des services la police des
polices et changer de l'enquête c'est
elle qui devra déterminer les
circonstances exactes de ce qui apparaît
déjà comme une bavure un mineur tué dans
un commissariat du 18e arrondissement à
Paris ce matin tout le monde parle de
bavure selon les premiers éléments le
ton serait monté durant une garde à vue
entre un inspecteur et la victime qui
était déjà connu des services de police
les circonstances
du accablante pour l'inspecteur qui a
tiré en aucun cas il n'avait le droit
d'utiliser son arme pendant la garde à
vue du mineur âgé de 17 ans une affaire
qui a provoqué une vie émotion aux
abords du commissariat parisien du côté
de la famille de la victime colère et
douleur bien sûr à l'annonce du drame
reportage de Christophe tortorat
Jean-Marc sur Saint Jean-François chevet
et les larmes d'une famille Mako
âgé de 17 ans leur fils leurs frères a
été tué hier au cours de sa garde à vue
touché par une balle tirée par l'arme du
policier qui l'interrogeait
[Applaudissements]
ages même pas de chaussures rien dans
ses poches
pouvez voir sur la tête de ma mère les
deux amis de Mako ayunella tout juste
relâché après leur garde à vue crier
leur désespoir les trois jeunes avaient
été arrêtés ensemble la veille
soupçonnée d'avoir participé à un
cambriolage selon ses dires lac lors de
son audition aurait également été menacé
par l'arme du même inspecteur devant moi
j'ai
la sortie
[Musique]
tenter d'expliquer ce qui a pu se passer
les syndicats de policiers déplore la
faute commise par l'inspecteur mais
invoque aussi les conditions de travail
encore une fois mais cette faute doit
pouvoir être placée aussi dans le
contexte dont je parlais de contexte de
ces conditions de travail absolument
épouvantables il faut le souligner et
donc personne ne personne n'a imagine
l'ampleur
l'inspecteur est toujours en garde à vue
dans les locaux de l'IGS la police des
polices des examens d'alcoolémie et des
recherches balistiques ont été ordonnées
une information judiciaire pourrait être
ouverte dès cet après-midi
plusieurs centaines de personnes sont en
ce moment même rassemblés devant le
commissariat des grandes carrières dans
le 18e arrondissement de Paris SOS
Racisme le bras le bras et plusieurs
autres organisations ont appelé à cette
manifestation pour protester contre la
mort cette nuit du jeune homme alors
nous y sommes en direct avec François
Guillaume François et bien Émilie les
300 personnes qui étaient réunies rue
Marcadet à quelques mètres du
commissariat ou mardi dernier ce jeune
zaïrois a trouvé la mort vienne de
partir ils se sont dirigés il y a
quelques instants vers le commissariat
situé à côté de la mairie du 18e
arrondissement 10 minutes plus tôt
l'ambiance ici était plutôt tendue
certains jeunes ont crié leur colère et
lancer des projectiles sur les gendarmes
les gendarmes qui n'ont pas riposter
dans la foule beaucoup d'amis du jeunes
zaïrois tués avant-hier également
d'autres personnes venues rendre hommage
à la victime
il y a trois quarts d'heure le père du
jeune zaïrois est arrivé accompagné de
faux destinales de présidents de SOS
Racisme au milieu de la rue se sont
élevés alors des pancartes où l'on
pouvait lire l'inscription historique de
l'association touche pas à mon pote
ensuite il faut décider à demander à
être reçu par le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour lui faire part de ses inquiétudes
des de ses propositions il faut des
Sylla demander plus de pédagogie et
moins de répression dans les
commissariats voilà ce qu'on peut dire à
cette heure ici à quelques mètres du
commissariat rue Marcadet
du nouveau pour la famille elle est
proche de Mako il s'agit d'un meurtre
d'un acte délibéré ils ont appris sa
mort hier dans la soirée 4h après les
faits et aujourd'hui réunis dans leur
appartement du 20e arrondissement de
Paris il ne s'explique toujours pas ce
qui s'est passé
dans un
commentaire
un enfant je savais pas que c'était mon
fils je savais pas que c'était mon fils
je
revenais du travail j'ai vu le policiers
de ça avec mon mari j'ai dit à mon mari
pas reconnaître un enfant
il s'est jamais avec les policiers comme
tous les adolescents qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait de mal cet enfant
c'était encore un enfant un jeune
rappeur de 17 ans comme il en existe
tant d'autres bien sûr Mako avait déjà
été interpellé plusieurs fois par la
police pour des délits mineurs mais il
n'était pas dangereux ses proches le
décrivent comme un garçon timide même si
il a évolu la terre entière on suit pas
quelqu'un comme ça il y a pas de
jugement qui se fait comme ça
ma commère a été assassinée par un
policier parce que moi j'appelle ça de
l'assassinat
est-ce que c'était quelqu'un de
dangereux pourquoi est-ce que
il n'était pas dangereux
sociologiquement une représentait aucun
danger un accident mais pour moi c'est
pas un accident parce que avant ils ont
dit que mon fils c'était débattu il
voulait retirer l'arme du policier mais
comment il pourrait le faire parce qu'il
avait le domaine
les parents qui ont perdu leur seul fils
exige maintenant des explications il
admettent pas que Mako le petit
délinquant soit mort comme un criminel
les réactions je vous le disais en titre
sont unanimes pour qu'on la met cette
bavure SOS Racisme qui s'inquiète du
climat d'insécurité que font régner les
forces de l'ordre sur la jeunesse le
Parti socialiste qui souhaite que la
faute soit sanctionnée comme il convient
et puis une mise au point de Charles
Pasqua sa sortie du Conseil des
ministres ce matin le ministre de
l'Intérieur a appelé les policiers à
faire preuve de maîtrise dans l'exercice
de leurs tâches on l'écoute
éventuellement des décisions
le rôle de la police et de protéger les
personnes et les biens chaque fois que
cela sera nécessaire elle sera soutenue
dès lors qu'il y aura des photographes
de commises elle sera les responsable
seront sanctionnés voilà et pour moi les
responsables ce sont pas seulement les
lampistes il faut que les choses soient
claires bonjour 3 bavures policières en
4 jours et une violente manifestation
hier soir à Paris devant le commissariat
du 18e arrondissement ou un jeune
zaïrois a été tué pendant sa garde à vue
mardi dernier le calme n'est revenu que
vers deux heures du matin 27 policiers
ont été légèrement blessés et 14
personnes sont encore en garde à vue
Huguette
fin de la manifestation les appelle au
calme sont déjà oubliés quelques jeunes
furieux lancent des projectiles pavés
bouteilles sur les garde mobiles postées
à l'entrée de la rue qui mène au
commissariat la violence se déplace très
rapidement dans les rues adjacentes et
près de la mairie du 18e les forces de
l'ordre harcelées riposte les
arrestations se multiplient
la nuit est maintenant tombée l'ambiance
reste électrique vitrine cassée voiture
incendiées face à face tendue le bilan
s'alourdit d'or en heure au total 27
blessés légers parmi les policiers deux
journalistes photographes blessés et une
dizaine de manifestants arrêtés 14 sont
encore en garde à vue le calme ne sera
rétabli que vers 2h du matin le calme
est revenu aujourd'hui dans le 18e
un nouveau manifester contre la mort du
jeune zaïrois makomé tué par un
inspecteur dans le commissariat des
grandes carrières 10 minutes après
l'annonce de la mise en examen pour
missiles volontaire de l'inspecteur la
manifestation a dégénéré aujourd'hui la
polémique a éclaté entre les syndicats
de police et leur hiérarchie 19h30 hier
soir devant le commissariat du 18e
arrondissement la manifestation
organisée par les airua pour dénoncer la
mort d'un des leurs dégénères très
rapidement la confusion est totale or le
sipn syndicat indépendant de la police
nationale accuse la hiérarchie
d'incompétence et d'imprévoyance selon
lui depuis 17 heures les états majeurs
étaient avisés que des casseurs de
banlieue se dirigeaient vers le 18e
arrondissement or rien n'aurait été fait
pour les arrêter ces jeunes se mêlé à
une manifestation des irons place le
jugeoffrin et en face du commissariat du
18e et puis alors qu'ils étaient mais le
bar de fer certains préparés même des
cocktails Molotov sur la plage public
derrière l'église qui êtes en face du
commissariat on avait mis aucun cordon
de sécurité pour les empêcher d'arriver
à cette manifestation des highwa une
fois qu'ils ont été mêlés à cette
manifestation comment voulez-vous les
extraire donc à chaque fois qu'on
interviendra pas au bon moment c'est à
dire au début de la manifestation qu'on
laisse pourrir la situation
automatiquement après ça dérape les
fonctionnaires de police 60 menacés ils
sont énervés et puis on maîtrise plus
rien
la préfecture de police n'a pas tenu à
faire de commentaires demain une
nouvelle manifestation zaïroise est
prévue à Paris une fois n'est pas
coutume le mouvement SOS Racisme s'est
félicité dans un communiqué des
sanctions prises par le mystère de
l'Intérieur allant contre des policiers
auteurs des dernières bavures 4 de ses
fonctionnaires de police je vous le
rappelle ont été suspendus des hier par
Charles Pasqua alors que l'inspecteur
responsable de la mort du jeûne zaïrois
dans un commissariat du 18e a été écroué
pour homicide volontaire un chef
d'accusation rarement retenu dans ce
genre d'affaires il faut dire que les
faits semblent accablant un haut
responsable de la police n'a pas hésité
à parler de bavure chimiquement pur
explication Christophe Tortora mardi
matin à 4h30 une patrouille de police
arrête trois jeunes au comportement
suspect lac âgé de 18 ans Ayun et Mako
tout de mineur ont suré pour plus de 20
000 francs de cigarettes ils sont
fortement soupçonnés d'avoir cambriolé
un bar-tabac immédiatement ils sont
conduits ici au commissariat des grandes
carrières le premier face à entre Mako
et l'inspecteur Compain a lieu à 6h30 le
policier lui signifie sa garde à vue et
il prévient normalement le parquet toute
la matinée il transmet des informations
au substitut du procureur qui ordonne à
12 heures la remise en liberté du jeune
zaïrois première faute de l'inspecteur
il ne tient pas compte de l'ordre de la
justice tout le reste de la procédure
l'inspecteur compa le fera donc en
dehors de tout cadre légal les parents
de Mako qui habitent ici port de
Bagnolet n'ont pas été prévenus de
l'arrestation de leur fils ils n'ont pas
le téléphone à 16h l'interrogatoire
reprend mais le ton monte si fort qu'à
16h15 le commissaire vient voir ce qui
se passe dans le bureau de l'inspecteur
il restera 10 minutes à 16h30 le jeune
homme aurait menacé le policier de le
retrouver à la sortie l'inspecteur
Compain sort alors son arme de service
autre faute le menace à bout portant une
balle atteint l'adolescent en pleine
tête Pascal Compain a été croué après
avoir été mise en examen pour homicide
volontaire un chef d'accusation très
rare dans une affaire impliquant ant un
policier
enfin dirais-je en matière de bavure
policière on trouve une qualification
appropriée au fait qu'ils sont
reprochaient à un policier l'inspecteur
Compain risque donc les assises à
l'image de la justice le ministre de
l'Intérieur Charles Pasqua a choisi la
fermeté puisque desiguières l'inspecteur
et le commissaire des grandes carrières
ont tous deux étaient suspendus
interdiction des rassemblements cet
après-midi c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur Charles Pasqua qu'il a
annoncé hier soir sur TF1 la
manifestation de protestation contre la
mort du jeune zaïrois dans le 18e
seraient annulée mais ce matin une
certaine agitation régnait déjà sur le
marché du quartier Marie-Pierre
courtelmont est Dominique bonnet
le racisme
les militants du collectif antiracistes
aura le front du XVIIIe arrondissement
face aux Front national
marché du poteau ce matin ambiance de
veiller d'armes avant la manifestation
interdite cet après-midi commissariat
sous haute protection magasin barricadé
commerçants et bien on a des ordres de
la mairie de fermer donc je pense que
vers 12h30 13h on va fermer comme nous
on habite pas ici je pense qu'on va
sortir parce que jeudi soir on ne
pouvait pas sortir d'ici et c'était
horrible vous êtes inquiet un peu comme
un main c'est moi
pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'il y a et à
la sécurité totale qui règne dans le
quartier depuis trois jours depuis 48
heures alors on se fait agresser par par
des macaques qui viennent de jeunes
séjour alors il faut bien se défendre
vous pouvez me montrer ce que vous avez
dans votre sac monsieur
qu'est-ce que c'est
une matraque télescopique
plusieurs organisations antiraciste
avaient appelé à une manifestation cet
après-midi après l'interdiction hier
soir du ministre de l'intérieur les
militants ont retiré le rappel en
nuances
nous ne pensons pas qu'il fallait
prendre le risque d’après une
manifestation interdite pour relancer la
logique de la répression des
interpellations des jeunes qui partent
dans les commissariats et des vitrines
cassées bon on pense que c'est pas
légitime par contre si il y a un
rassemblement qui est un rassemblement
légitime des jeunes on sera avec
à quelques heures d'éventuelles
rassemblement les esprits Sochaux donc
d'arom
atisés une affaire de bavure policière
dont on avait beaucoup parlé au mois
d'avril 93 cette affaire arrive devant
la justice il s'agit de l'affaire du
jeune macomé ce zaïrois tué pendant sa
garde à vue au commissariat des grandes
carrières dans le 18e arrondissement de
Paris deux ans après l'effet
l'inspecteur de police auteur de la
bavure devrait bientôt être renvoyé
devant les assises et la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de Paris
examiné aujourd'hui pour quel chef
d'incubation coût mortel ou meurtre dans
les deux cas le policier risque de 20 à
30 ans de réclusion ils vont à loin
Michel Rey
le 6 avril 93 il est 17h un coup de feu
claque dans l'une des pièces sombres du
commissariat des grandes carrières dans
le 18e arrondissement macomé un jeune
zaïrois de 17 ans s'écroule tu es sur le
coup d'une balle dans la tête arrêté
dans la nuit en possession de cigarette
volley dans un débit de tabac c'est
adolescent déjà connu des services de
police pour vol et brutalité et placés
en garde à vue avec deux complices
l'interrogatoire est mené par Pascal
Compain un inspecteur immature selon ses
collègues une tête brûlée selon sa
hiérarchie et qui refuse de libérer
macomé malgré la décision du parquet le
ton monte les insultes pleuvent Pascal
Compain sort son arme de service pour
intimider les ailes rois une menace de
trop la suite n'est qu'une série de
cafouillage les témoins ne pourront pas
préciser si ma commun a tenté de
s'emparer du revolver un point pourtant
essentiel pour déterminer le chef
d'incubation y a-t-il eu homicide
volontaire ou coup mortel sans attention
délibérée de tuer après la demande de
renvoi du parquet la chambre
d'accusation du tribunal de Paris a
entendu cet après-midi les parties
civils et la défense ce qui me permet de
croire qu'il n'y a pas eu homicide
volontaire c'est que d'abord
l'inspecteur compte pas n'est pas un
tueur que rien n'est jamais venu
démontrer qu'il a eu à quelques moments
que ce soit la volonté de tuer et
d'autre part les éléments objectifs du
dossier qui permettent de savoir qu'un
certain moment la victime s'est saisi ou
a eu les mains posées sur cette arme ce
qui a pu engendrer la crispation sur la
détente si tel était le cas Pascal
Compain risquerait 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle au lieu de 30 quant à
l'avocat des parties civils il n'a pas
souhaité donner sa version des faits le
jugement a été mis en délibéré au 23
mars prochain le procès de Pascal compas
a débuté cet après-midi le policier est
jugé pour homicide volontaire il a tiré
à bout portant avec son revolver de
service sur un jeune zaïrois qu'il était
chargé d'interroger c'était en avril 93
Pascal Compain risque 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle les Rivoire et Marc
Savino ont assisté à cette première
demi-journée de procès où l'on est
revenu sur la personnalité de l'accusé
dans la salle de la cour d'assises le
face à face entre un père et l'homme qui
a tué son fils j'attends que je sois
prête
que ça soit pas une parodie mais une
vraie justice cet homme c'est parce
qu'elle compare inspecteur au
commissariat des grandes carrières un
endroit où il n'avait pas sa place selon
sa hiérarchie toujours en retard
fantaisiste et nonchalant ces notes sont
tout justement moyenne parce qu'elle
Compain lui préférait le terrain le
contact au travail de commissariat il
reconnaît lui-même qu'il aurait préféré
une autre affectation et que c'est bien
à regret qu'il est allé au commissariat
des grandes terres pour taper sur une
vieille machine à écrire cette heure par
jour que
fais ce policier aussi
uniquement se contenter de faire le
procès d'un policier qui même dans une
situation dramatique de toutes les
façons sera amen à payer pour ce qu'il a
fait sans reposer la question de
responsabilité collective et y compris
de la rachie policière et la partie
civile veut aussi faire de ce procès
celui de l'institution policière mais
parce qu'elle Compain décrit par ses
amis comme un bon vivant amateur de
femmes devra répondre seul de son geste
meurtrier les jurés de la cour d'assises
de Paris ont condamné l'ex inspecteur de
police parce qu'elle Compain à 8 ans de
prison pour le meurtre d'un zaïrois 17
ans tué lors de sa garde à vue dans un
commissariat du 18e arrondissement 93 le
parquet avait demandé une peine minimale
de 10 ans de réclusion un verdicto qui a
suscité une vive émotion chez les amis
de la victime sur place Dominique
verdaillon Jacques Gérard
le verdict à peine tombé des cris on
retentit dans la salle d'audience puis
dans la salle des pas perdus les proches
de makomé crient leur déception leur
colère s'en prennent violemment au juge
c'est scandaleux pour la République
bravo la France on y abat des gens comme
des chiens bousculade bridglas jet
bouteille on brandit le portrait de
jeunes gens tués par d'autres policiers
puis les gendarmes finiront par évacuer
les manifestants par la grande porte du
palais de justice à quelques mètres de
là les larmes d'une mère j'ai confiance
en la justice avait-elle dit hier soir à
la barre mais le verdict n'est pas celui
qu'elle attendait la cour d'assise a
suivi la défense et non l'accusation
c'est un accident et non un meurtre
verdict 8 ans de prison
je croyais à une vraie justice mais là
on vient d'assister à une véritable
parodie de la justice
qui est purement et simplement raciste
ça je le dis je le cache pas soulagement
en revanche côté défense qui avait
plaidé la faute grave et qui comprend la
déception des victimes
on les a peut-être un peu bercer
d'illusion c'est peut-être une erreur je
comprends très bien ce désarroi mais la
justice elle est ce qu'elle est et elle
doit être rendue d'une manière sereine
et je pense qu'elle a été et
curieusement l'accusation et l'accusé
ont tenté cet après-midi de faire passer
le même message l'avocat général conjure
les policiers de ne plus sortir d'armes
de leur bureau dans un commissariat
quant à Pascal Compain il déclare que ce
drame servent au moins de leçon à mes
collègues ces derniers mots seront plus
jamais ça
[Musique]